alors vous arrivés tous les deux de
cannes du festival de cannes vous avez
trouvé comment le festival harvey iphone
fait
moi j'ai trouvé que le festival était
absolument formidable jeu les jurys ont
fait un excellent choix
cette décision avec laquelle j'étais pas
d'accord et que cet effet n'est le plus
que réduit et horreur meilleur rôle
féminin toute seule elle n'avait pas
besoin de tout
tout cet aéropage féminin autour d'elle
harvey vous avez déclaré pour moi le
meilleur film réalisé sur los angeles
chinatown de polanski le meilleur film
réalisé sur new york c'est macadam
cowboy de john schlesinger le meilleur
vie de gangster sait il était une fois
en amérique de sergio leone
tous ces réalisateurs sont venues
d'europe
il faut défendre la diversité culturelle
en europe
c'est rare de la part d'un producteur
américain entendre ça et voyez vous moi
je j'y crois beaucoup à la diversité
culturelle mais en plus et sage beatty
par le passé je le répéterai il me
semble que la france et d'autres pays
doivent justement protéger leur cinéma
contre justement le cinéma mais quand
même six mois je suis américain joue 10
argos
pourquoi parce que les américains ne
rendent pas honneur aux français on n'a
pas été les à des émissions françaises
et pourtant l'inversé vrai n'a pas
présenté de films français en tant que
fille ni à la télévision une femme
depuis 40 ans alors comment où est la
justice où l'équité par rapport aux
français anglais ou encore au cinéma
allemand ou espagnol a aucune justice
lat en moi j'adore le cinéma j'avais 10
ans dans un cinéma chez les voir ce film
les 400 coups de françois truffaut je
restais un film érotique
parce que le titre bull aux forains le
blues la traduction de 400 coups ça
faisait penser au blowjobs ou pipe on a
fait quatre des kilomètres sous la neige
pour aller voir ce film
il n'y a que mon frère et moi qui avons
vu ce film parce que tout le monde était
déçu film en noir et blanc avec des sous
titres
pas une seule eric enfin toujours est il
que 8 et mes copains ont quitté le
cinéma en cours en disant allez vous
faire voir les pubs et moi on est resté
et on est tombé amoureux du cinéma
français ce jour-là l'âge de 10 ans avec
le film de truffaut reset humus en amour
du foot alors vous êtes né à brooklyn
dans la banlieue de new york
votre père s'appelait max il était
diamantaire il vous a mené tous les
samedis au cinéma il aimait tous les
genres sauf les films de guerre parce
qu'ils avaient combattu pendant la
guerre il fallait plus en parler de la
guerre se situe au c'est vraiment ça en
effet mon frère et moi on adorait les
films d'errol flynn qui sauvait la
mairie mais mon père ne pouvait pas
supporter ce film il ya un film si pour
moi tout démystifier s'était il faut
sauver le soldat ryan white pourquoi
parce que jusqu'à ce que je voie ce film
je ne me comprenait pas ce que mon père
à z mais mon père avait vu justement la
guerre il avait participé à des patins
et c'est pour ça qu'ils pouvaient pas
voir de film de guerre à moins qu'il ne
dise la vérité est très peu de films
bollywood de présenter la réalité on en
faisait tout un film de propagande
autour de l'amérique mais on voyait
jamais du sens les palmes tu aies jamais
personne n'était pas vraiment la vision
réelle de la guerre en votre mère
s'appelle myriam elle est toujours
vivante et elle pense encore que le
cinéma est un job occasionnels et vous
dit qu'elle n'a pas encore perdu
l'espoir que vous deveniez médecin mais
à 81 ans et si quelqu'un a besoin d'une
bonne mère juive elle est là pour elle
peut
vérifiez les les venues aux jeux
olympiques pour la discipline
je me plains de tout et s'il ya
quelqu'un qui a un souci
elle peut se faire du souci pour tout le
monde en 1979 augmenté avec votre frère
une société qui s'appelle miramax du nom
de vos parents myriam et max voilà et
alors vous allez au festival de cannes
au début des années 80 je n'ai pas
d'argent vous connaissez personne et
vous êtes dans un placard à balais à
l'hôtel majestic
c'était un placard à balais et j'ai
dormi avec mon frère heureusement que
mon frère parce que sinon il y aurait eu
toutes sortes de rumeurs à mon sujet
personne ne m'a invitée avait filmé dans
le palais des festivals la constition
ficelles donc je le suis infiltré comme
on le faisait entrer par les portes de
sortie par les issues de secours et ont
aussi baissé sur les marchés puis les
gendarmes sont venus le pick and go
évitons vous quittez la salle celui qui
était juste à côté de moi qui étais sur
un essai demain tranquille et c'était
c'était sean connery en personne qui
nous est légendaire alors jeunes gens
des retraités vent monsieur bond a dit
bon nous ont laissés à rester dans la
salle et c'était la première fois que
j'y rencontre riche en conneries vingt
ans plus tard j'ai raconté cette
histoire
lorsque j'ai eu l'honneur de lui
présenter un film dans le cadre du film
festival depuis les niveaux et lui
raconter anecdotes il a beaucoup ri
parce que c'est le genre de personne
qu'il est les sig et métro
alors voilà donc en 1981 arrive in sync
et son premier festival de cannes et dix
ans plus tard dans un autre festival de
sundance organisé par robert redford
vous repérez sexe mensonges et vidéo des
soderbergh et c'est le début du succès
vous inventez le blockbuster sur le film
qui marche indépendant ah oui je sais
pas si j'ai inventé ce genre cela étant
moi il me semble que un grand film n'a
pas besoin d'être confiné aux ghettos
des films d'art et essai sexe mensonges
et vidéo vous pouvez le voir dans le
monde entier il fallait pas le confiner
aux petites salles
le fait qu'un film c'est intelligent ne
signifie pas qu'il soit limité
c'est les mauvais films qui devraient
être limitées mais des films
intelligents de ground large public au
contraire
votre autre grande spécialité harvey
c'est la course aux oscars vous dépenser
des millions de dollars en publicité en
soirée spéciale en cadeau sans parler
des coups de fil avec un acharnement au
delà du réel pour avoir des oscars vous
promettez aux acteurs que ce titre avec
vous ils vont avoir la petite statuette
dorée
il ya 250 domination à se jouer à
quelque 71 et hincapie
alors oui ça l'est pour moi
l'académie les os cassé la façon de
commercialiser d'autres évidemment on a
investi beaucoup de temps d'efforts
l'attend mais quelquefois il ya un petit
film comme le son piano ou game ou
shakespeare in love ou le patient mais
n'auraient normalement pas trouvé un
grand public à travers le monde mais
c'est évidemment losc rackettaient le
tremplin qui leur a permis d'avoir ce
mardi alors pas simplement pas
nécessairement meilleur film est aussi
une meilleur rôle masculin ou féminin
évidemment ça aide énormément un film
allait prochainement
vous avez la vie qu'à jouer marianne
routier qui a joué cap j'ai vu 20
minutes de ce film à cannes et sa
prestation je suis sûr qu'elle
mériterait un oscar en tout cas elle
sera nominée cotillard dans la vie de
l'un le piaf ont réalisé par olivier
dahan est produit par il
goldman alors on vous reproche quand
même harvey un certain irrespect pour
les oeuvres ont dit que vous coupez que
vous remontez les films les français dit
vous vous appelle d'artagnan à cause du
sabre et on vous appelle aussi six
organs harvey c'est vous un violent
tacle de charles après l'émission
je vais vous montrer la version de cinq
heures de gangs de new york et vous
comprendrez mai et si vous arrivez à
tenir trois heures chapeau 1
alors le plus grand honneur que j'ai
reçu c'est que martin scorsese dit
maintenant la version de deux heures et
demie hélas la seule berceau qu'il
présentera donc lui en est content il
n'y a que la concurrence qui m'accusent
d'être crs parce qu'ils sont jaloux mais
nous nous disons la vérité et en disant
la vérité en face
nous emportons les palmes d'or les
oscars il a l'habitude de dire la vérité
alors c'est vrai pour un metteur en
scène quand on lui dit son fils ils ont
un cdi il disait c'est difficile et les
metteurs en scène sont entourés de
collaborateurs qui n'osent pas
paris est un peu brusque mais souvent
essentiels alors il faut s'habituer à
tort aux états unis vous savez conteste
les films sur des publics ce n'est prévu
avant de les sortir et on apprend
beaucoup et malheureusement il a souvent
raison c'est à dire que la conclusion du
public c'est un peu ce qui l'a anticipé
mais il le fait à la fin avec la
collaboration des metteurs en scène des
producteurs est ce que est ce que
patrice chéreau est content de la
version courte de la reine margot vous
avez distribué aux états unis irene qui
s'appellera qu'il est très satisfait et
hamilton
je crois que la seule chose qui a
empêché le film d'être un plus grand
succès encore c'est que johnny tu es
censé venir en amérique pour faire la
promotion
or elle avait des problèmes personnels
n'a pas besoin mais c'était là
c'était une déception qu'ils appellent
dispagne mais toutes les critiques
étaient très bonne sur l'arène mac os et
on estime que c'est l'un des grands
films français
j'étais zoulou et c'est la version
courte c'est vrai mais l'a dit qu'ils
étaient très contents de voir ce film
parle est très adroit pour lui en tant
que juif trouvé que c'était un
soulagement de voir des protestants à
des catholiques qui circulent en toute
hâte d'avoir des juifs qui sont
assassinés c'était un très très relaxant
alors on vous reproche aussi d'être
terriblement dur en affaire harvey il ya
une phrase qui compte sur vous à
hollywood qui dit si vous ne vous êtes
jamais fait baiser par miramax si vous
n'avez jamais travaillé avec eux eyepet
hommes et leur game et le viol alors là
encore ceux qui disent ça généralement
se cachent derrière l'anonymat
ce qui est souvent ce sont des gens qui
n'ont pas de succès est-ce que vous avez
le nom de l'auteur de cette citation
n'at il ya que les lâches qui diront des
choses pareilles en 1993 ou vendait donc
à disney la société miramax bbc ce qui
s'est passé c'est que tous les metteurs
en scène découvrez tout le talent mais
nous n'avions pas les moyens
malgré notre succès nous n'étions quand
même une petite maison de production
donc pour celle qui a réalisé my left
foot nous a quittés pour aller à une
bulle sont parce que nous y opposer
mieux
alors évidemment on aurait proposé
davantage si on avait pu mais nous ne
pouvions pas dossier quand nous nous
sommes vendus à des zones et ils ont
décidé de nous donner les moyens de
travailler avec ces réalisateurs
isautier très bien au départ un des sept
premières années de la collaboration
avec des années ont été excellentes on a
fait profession
ils se sont un peu mêler de ça mais
disons que on pouvait naviguer assez
bien et on a fait tout un sporting on a
fait beaucoup de films très controversé
mais
après doc main et fahrenheit man eleven
où ils ont refusé
lord of the rings bon là ça a commencé à
mal tourner disney vous a refusé le
seigneur des anneaux j'avais développé
un projet avec peter jackson
j'ai mis 10 millions de dollars pour
développer toute la technologie des
tonnages en nouvelle-zélande pour
pouvoir faire ce que vous avez vu à
l'écran les trois scénarios ont été
développés par nous j'allais voir dénis
jeudi puis de jackson de faire trois
films nouveaux 180 millions $ parce que
j'avais un plafond mais je pouvais pas
aller au delà de 75 millions c'est tout
ce que je peux dépenser quand j'étais
aux commandes et j'aurais dit il m'en
faut plus je voulais faire 3-3 ont dit
non non seulement on n'y croyait pas
seigneur des anneaux mais ils m'ont dit
je conserverai une partie des recettes
en tant que producteur veilleux et
garder les sous
puisque je n'y croyais pas c'est comme
ça que faut qu'on se qualifie donc ça
plus faranah est le film de michael
moore vous avez quittez donc votre
association avec disney ils ont produit
phare un acte qui a gagné à cannes
michael moore et disney a refusé de le
distribuer parce que il attaque et bien
sûr le président bush son frère et lui
ont sorti un chèque ont payé le film
l'ont acheté
quelle erreur pour disney et l'on
distribue dans le monde entier avec le
succès que vous connaissez courage et
alors que nous tout est donc votre
association avec disney et vous avez
monté une nouvelle société qui s'appelle
the weinstein company vous disposez d'un
milliard de dollars dont ça laisse
rêveur soit pour faire des films
ils ont un milliard de dollars évitant
le cinéma il relevé un milliard de
dollars donc associé avec tarak ben
ammar tsébo d'ailleurs de voir le juif
de brooklyn qui était associé avec le le
musulman de de tunis est assez jolie
histoire
1 c'est la bible c'est la bible avec
vous il ya des français et des européens
il ya tf1 il ya patrick le lay qui est
associé avec vous il ya lvmh aussi qui
est associé avec vous c'est assez voilà
c'était celle cuménique finalement des
japonais un chinois un c'est vraiment
une compagnie internationale est très
européenne ouais tout en étant
américaine avec bob est ravi qu'ils
détiennent 50% de la compagnie 50 ou 51
oui un bug in shore on est là or voilà
donc parmi les premiers films de cette
société il y en a un qui s'appelle yang
hannibal le jeune animal qui est un
prequel de la fameuse série du silence
des agneaux avec gaspard ulliel alors
c'est très gonflé d'avoir pris gaspard
ulliel
mais ça c'est la députée de taxi lui
qu'on a découvert de certains
conducteurs du film l'année dernière à
cannes m'a présenté à casting avec cinq
minutes aux questions qui avait été
abolie tous les acteurs américains
même le plus grand nous voulait ce rôle
j'ai vu ce casting
c'est absolument extraordinaire se gare
sera très très loin hilaire et
incarnation de anthony hopkins
mais le courage de rares vie c'est de
confier parce que le film sortira dans
3500 salles le 9 février aux états unis
dans le monde entier
c'est la première fois qu'un budget de
cette importance est confiée à un jeune
acteur français et ça c'est gaz par leur
compagnie ouais même avec le test de
gaspard eu elle ne m'aurait pas suivi
parce qu'ils auraient dit comment on va
le promouvoir
or vis et comment le promouvoir et pour
l'histoire naturellement c'est pourquoi
un tony hawk qui nous est devenu un
électeur donc c'est la vie du jeune
hannibal et on expliquera on ne dira pas
ici pourquoi il est devenu moi je le
sais